sábado 30 de agosto de 2002
mi padre salía de un almuerzo con mi
madre y con cuatro de sus amigos
de pronto se enfrentaron con seis
policías armados con metralletas que la
apuntaban
no dijeron nada
se limitaron a llevarse a mi padre en
una van y desapareció
y mi madre y sus amigos sabían a dónde
nos llevaron
esta tarde lo golpearon lo torturaron y
lo encerraron en una jaula para perros
en el antiguo aeropuerto de quito en la
madrugada se subieron a un avión el
golpeado maltratado y se lo llevaron a
los eeuu
la vida de mi padre cambió
dramáticamente desde ese momento
estaba jubilado ya antes dos años
regresó a su país natal
a descansar y disfrutar de su familia y
sus amigos pero en ese momento ya había
perdido su libertad
durante algunas semanas lo mantuvieron
incomunicados llevando su derecho al
debido proceso
su nueva realidad era el estar solo
sentirse amenazado atacado y torturado
lo acusaron de haber asesinado a cuatro
personas
aquí él había sido el crimen más
espantoso de la historia de un condado
de poch en estado de florida
pero un condado que todavía existe un
marcado racismo y mi padre es latino
la nueva realidad de mi padre era esa la
prisión los abusos y un juicio en el que
se lo que sería sin pruebas de ese
crimen
durante doscientos treinta y ocho días
fue recogido a una celda de castigo en
total soledad sin ropa sin cobija
sin jabón o acceso a sus cosas de
higiene
las paredes cubiertas en excremento
humano
aire acondicionado permanente y a tope
luces de estadio 24 horas del día para
que no pudiera dormir
intentaron doblegarlo enfermarlo y
enloquecer lo pero él se mantuvo entero
y sobrevivió
cuatro años después sin evidencias en su
contra
lo condenaron a la pena de muerte
lunes primero de septiembre del 2002 una
llamada de teléfono cambió mi vida de
forma radical
era mi madre que envuelta en un llanto
incontenible me dijo que mi padre había
desaparecido
empecé a buscar abogados de expertos en
pena capital
para cubrir los gastos de estos abogados
tuvimos que vender todo lo que tenía
nuestra familia
en este momento yo era padre de dos
niños siete y tres años
estaba divorciando me
era dueño de mi propia compañía de
ingeniería y ahora me encontraba armando
un equipo de defensa
autor de canto me solo sistema judicial
estadounidense
y tratando de comprender cómo realmente
funcionaba la justicia en la florida
quiere descubrir sobre el sistema
judicial de la florida
descubrí aunque la estructura del
sistema era teóricamente buena las
personas dentro del sistema los fiscales
y los jueces que eran elegidos por voto
popular estaban manipulando el sistema
por el bien de sus carreras que los
estos fiscales y estos jueces se
destacaban por la porcentaje de
sanciones y era como un premio lograr
sentenciar a alguien a la pena de muerte
otra cosa que descubriste una persona
sin plata no tenía el derecho
de la garantía de justicia o el debido
proceso la florida tenía la segunda
población más alta de personas en el
corredor de la muerte y al mismo tiempo
eran primero en ser obligados en
exonerar personas inocentes y por mala
conducta
una persona de color latino
de ser culpado un crimen capital
en comparación con un blanco era 3.2
veces más probable que sea sancionado y
además ser castigado el máximo que la
ley dictaba
quiero darles unos ejemplos
el primer ejemplo que quiero contarles
son de los williams
con solo dos días de juicio de este tío
y este sobrino en el año 1976 fueron
dados la pena de muerte
fueron exonerados en el año 2019
encontraron después de 43 años que el
fiscal desde entonces había manipulado
las evidencias
el próximo caso es el del south field
sentenciado a la pena de muerte por
haber asesinado a su esposa
leo salió después de 25 años estar en el
corredor de la muerte el fiscal al
fiscal encontraron que él había
escondido una huella digital del
verdadero asesino
este asesino era de serie acusado por el
mismo fiscal ese mismo mes del año 1987
y era por seis homicidios en la misma
región
este fiscal aunque descubrieron esto de
él siguió trabajando sin problema sin
perjuicio y terminó siendo el fiscal
y estaba en el caso de mi padre
próximo caso quiero contarles es de
clemente javier aguirre
sentenciado a muerte en 2006 por
asesinar sus vecinos
acusado por la nieta de una de las
víctimas pero que también era la
verdadera asesina
pero el testimonio de esta chica no
cuadraba con ninguna de las evidencias
forensic as
pero igual al aguirre un hondureño
indocumentado
no fue liberado hasta el año 2019
estoy un caso más y éste es de pablo
pablo ibar en el año 94 a los 22 años de
un espanyol fue sentenciado a la pena de
muerte sin evidencias menos un vídeo
bien borroso que podía haber sido
cualquiera
españa lo defiende vigorosamente hasta
el día de hoy
ahora hay muchos muchos más
pero se deja con una estadística que
acaba de salir actualmente en los eeuu
hay un promedio de más de 3
exoneraciones por semana
otros descubrimientos que quiero
compartir es que el condado de poch
tenía más violaciones de los derechos
humanos tienen más quejas de mala
conducta fiscal y tiene más muertos que
están encarcelados en todos los estados
unidos'
al día de hoy el ku klux klan sigue
mensualmente y abiertamente reuniéndose
la corte suprema de eeuu ha dictaminado
en varias ocasiones de que la florida ha
actuado y incondicionalmente en cuanto a
la pena de muerte la última vez fue en
2016 y otra cosa muy preocupante es que
la flora y la florida tiene una ley que
prohíbe sancionar a fiscales y a jueces
por mala conducta
este era lo que yo me enfrentaba
esto era lo que yo tenía que entender y
pelear
tuve que enfrentar a este monstruo
enorme que no tenía límite de recursos y
tiene todo el poder
ante esta situación ante este monstruo
que se me venía encima me pregunte
por donde debía empezar
porque debía ser
decidí entonces que tenía que empezar
con mí mismo
tenía que aceptar lo sucedido y entender
de lo que había pasado no me definía a
mí como persona
sino más bien yo me iba a definir por
las acciones que yo iba a tomar
pensé yo no soy hijo de un prisionero en
el corredor de la muerte más bien son
alguien que estoy tratando de sacar a la
luz la verdad para que libere a mi padre
la clave en estos instantes era tomar
acción así que la estructura y vida
incorporando a esta nueva realidad en
que había caído
lo primero que tuve que hacer es crear
un sistema de prioridades lo primero era
mis hijos después tenía que ser mi
compañía
tercero tenía que reconocer que era de
mi padre y después del resto del mundo
a veces solo tenemos poco tiempo al día
para lograr una cosa
y a veces este sistema que yo tenía me
ayudaba en tanto como un ejemplo todo lo
que es relacionado con mis hijos tiene
prioridad sobre las metas de mi compañía
esta escala de prioridades resultó
entonces esencial para lograr algo en
vez de quedarme lamentándome o estancado
por la frustración
y el dolor que nos embargaba
en estos momentos de la vida más que
otras circunstancias yo llegué a evaluar
y redefinir mis principios
mis creencias y mi relación con dios
es sumamente importante tomar tiempo
todos los días para evaluar tu relación
con ti mismo con tu mundo y con tu
espiritualidad
una sorpresa que tuve personalmente
fue cuando empecé a ayudar a otros
aunque parece que comprometerte a ayudar
a otros solo te quita tiempo que piensas
que no lo tienes
pero ayudar a otros fue una inversión
que me entregó mucha riqueza y sabiduría
sobre mí mismo y de lo que yo pensaba
que había aprendido
al final de esta examinación personal
entendí también que no podía auto
juzgarme
que más bien sin importar los logros y
los fracasos de ayer
tienes que levantarte de todas las
mañanas pies al suelo mirar adelante y
decirte
qué puedo hacer hoy para acercarme a mis
objetivos
con esta fortaleza en frente al monstruo
de un sistema judicial que todos piensan
que es infalible que es perfecto pero
está manchado por la corrupción por el
racismo y por los propios vicios del
sistema
el fiscal que acoso mi padre debería
presentarse a elecciones en el año 2002
no eres favorita de esas elecciones
porque por cinco años no pudo encontrar
el culpable del crimen más espantoso de
esa área él necesitaba un culpable para
seguir su carrera
y mi padre un latino que había sido
socio de uno de los asesinados
la posibilidad de ser reelegido
en efecto el logro la elección pero así
funciona este sistema perverso
ese 31 de agosto del año 2002 la vida de
mi familia cambió por completo hoy han
pasado casi 17 años desde que
secuestraron a mi padre y lo encerraron
en una celda 2 metros por 3
el ahora tiene 81 años está enfermo
ciego en un ojo casi completamente sordo
pero es un hombre que no se deja
doblegar por nada
el aceptar al destino que le reserva su
vida ya sea la inyección letal o la
libertad
de igual manera él está listo
nosotros todavía creemos en la justicia
todavía confiamos que está saldrá libre
cómo salieron esas personas acusadas
injustamente
florida necesita desesperadamente una
reforma de la justicia penal
y la pena de muerte debe ser abolida
ya que la florida no defiende a sus
ciudadanos de la manipulación de estos
casos capitales
piénsenlo
si un fiscal manipula el juicio para
obtener una pena de muerte y le matan a
un inocente el fiscal está cometiendo
asesinato premeditado y agravado de
primer grado y la florida es su cómplice
al proporcionar dinero y poder
ilimitados y además recuerdan que a esa
ley que tiene que al fiscal no hay como
sancionarle por sus actos
yo sigo peleando y intentando que ese
sistema judicial cambie y que
desaparezca la pena de muerte
y sobre todo que nunca más haya la
corrupción que permite sancionar a gente
inocente
créalo o no
la próxima víctima puede ser tú